[Music]
good morning it is 7 a.m you're watching
sky news breakfast it's day 13 of the
russian invasion ukraine has accused
moscow of a medieval style siege to try
and batter it into submission russia's
advance has been frustrated but they
have intensified artillery strikes on
city centres and residential areas food
water and medicine are growing scarce
more talks between russia and ukraine
are expected to take place today and
there's a promised ceasefire but
previous attempts to allow civilians to
escape have failed we'll be asking the
defense secretary ben wallace what more
the uk can do to help
it is tuesday the 8th of march
russia intensifies its attacks on
besieged ukrainian cities
a new ceasefire is due to start right
now but it comes after three days of
broken promises
ukraine says it's killed a second
russian general in fighting near kharkiv
president zielinski vows to stay in kiev
until the war is won he'll be addressing
british mps in the house of commons via
video link this evening
more than 1.7 million people have fled
ukraine for neighboring countries 300
have been granted visas to come to the
uk
as russia threatens to cut off europe's
gas supply in retaliation for western
sanctions
well this is the scene in the ukrainian
capital kiev this morning
and also on the programme we'll hear
what it's like living under russian
occupation in the city of kerason
ukraine's only big city to have been
captured so far
and i'll be speaking to a ukrainian
woman who got married during the first
days of the war and has taken up arms
with her new husband
[Music]
good morning ukraine's president has
again accused russia of attacking
civilians he rallied his people in a
late night address saying that ukraine's
resistance was making the war like a
nightmare for moscow and today he'll
make a historic appeal to mps in britain
via video link in the house of commons
for more international assistance
now let's take you through the latest
developments russia has said that a new
ceasefire is in force as of 7 am this
morning to allow civilians to escape
besieged cities but most of those safe
routes offered by russia go to russia or
to its partner belarus
and according to the u.s department of
defense as russia's advance has slowed
they've stepped up missile and artillery
strikes on city centers and civilian
infrastructure
well local authorities report that 10
people including children have been
killed in an aerial attack on a
residential building in the northeastern
city of sui
ukraine's defense agency claims a second
russian general vitali gerasimov has
been killed in fighting near kharkiv
well greg milam has our first report
to the list of what's been destroyed in
ukraine we can now add this pre-school
in the second largest city of kharkiv
the high school next door also struck
every day this war is shattering more
and more civilian lives
the message from ukraine's president is
that he's going nowhere filming himself
in his office for the first time since
the invasion began
yesterday
i stay here in kiev at bankover street i
don't hide and i'm not afraid of anyone
i will stay here as long as it's
necessary to win our patriotic war
nashi which is
and across his country the sounds of war
rumble on here in the coastal city of
mikolayev every promise of a ceasefire
and the precious chance for people to
reach safety has been broken so far
i have tears running down my face
although i'm a tight soldier my wife was
injured by shrapnel yesterday she's now
at hospital number four
she was just about saved there
now she's there and i'm here trying to
sort things out somehow
there's little optimism today's
ceasefire will be any more successful
ukrainian cities are under siege
under relentless russian shelling
hospitals are running out of supplies
food is adrenaline
and civilian countries are mounting
with no let up in the death and
destruction in ukraine what of the
economic punishment for russia the u.s
perhaps about to do what europe says it
can't and stop importing russian oil
whatever the cost to the markets and
consumers
it can mean little to the youngest
victims of this crisis this boy crossing
the border into poland safe yes but how
can we ever measure the damage that's
already been done to so many others greg
milam sky news washington
all right let's take you now to the
ukrainian border with romania where uh
our correspondent alistair buncombe is
standing by
good morning to you so just give us a
situation as you understand it where you
are at that border crossing
well i mean all hopes on
another ceasefire this morning that has
just come into force but i think those
hopes uh will be rather thin based on
previous ceasefires over the last three
days this would be the fourth and all
previous ones
have failed for various reasons either
because
one of the sides has broken it through
through force i say either one of the
sides both sides blame each other as you
can imagine
but also because what russia is
proposing is frankly pretty unpalatable
to most people even
however desperate they are and that is
because the humanitarian corridors that
the russians have set up a lead for the
most part either into belarus or into
russia and so you're asking people uh to
flee into the arms of their attackers
effectively and there's real skepticism
because of the propaganda win that it
could give russia you can imagine the
pictures that russian television would
then get uh showing ukrainians fleeing
to russia
and being used uh to the russian
propaganda machines uh advantage saying
look you know they are coming to us and
look how we are receiving them and so
that is why there's a great degree of
skepticism about these ceasefires and
france's president emmanuel macron who's
been trying to negotiate them has
distanced themselves from the russian
proposals and instead wants humanitarian
corridors that lead into uh well either
safer parts of ukraine or into western
europe uh and as uh you're in uh romania
on the border with ukraine there uh how
many more people have been seeking to
cross in the past 24 hours and what kind
of conditions are they living in i mean
we can see behind you it looks cold it's
snowy
yeah i'm particularly particularly this
morning um it is cold it is snowing um
in terms of exact numbers uh we don't
know but well into the thousands every
day we've been here for about a week and
it's pretty much non-stop we haven't
seen any let up in the number of people
that are that are coming in and it is
hour after hour day after day uh just a
regular stream through the border i mean
they are they are looked after very very
well here once they get here as best as
the authorities can do at least some of
them stick around um perhaps unsure what
to do they've left their homes in a
hurry they don't have much on them and
they don't really have a plan i mean
that is entirely understandable but
others do have a plan they have perhaps
relatives or friends elsewhere in europe
and that is where they want to head to
and if that's uh what they want to do
then they are they are helped along
their way either by train uh or or by
plane if they if they can do and we've
had a lot of people wanting to go to
places like germany and poland a lot
want to go to to italy as well so that
is the kind of shape of things here
and i don't see any let up at the moment
as the as the conflict spreads uh i
think it will will only sort of increase
and we'll see more and more refugees
come in already the worst humanitarian
crisis uh since the uh the second world
war in europe absolutely right u.n
saying some five million people will be
displaced alistair for now in romania
thank you very much for that now
ukraine's former president petro
podeshenko has told sky news that
ukraine will beat back and defeat
russia's superior military force but he
said it would take longer and cost more
lives without western support now every
day the number of ukrainian civilians
killed and injured in the war continues
to rise our special correspondent alex
crawford reports now from europe close
to the capital kiev
they know all about civilians being
attacked here this small village
community just south of the ukrainian
capital
has been torn apart by russian bombs
almost an entire street disappeared in
an instant
three children and three adults were
killed devastating their families and
the whole neighborhood
the explosions have left a deep burning
anger and a thirst for revenge amongst
the men of the village who've taken up
arms to defend their community and their
country
i feel only hate he tells us we'll never
ever forgive them for this
those who survived the explosions are
still sifting through what's left of
their lives to piece together precious
possessions or memories
oksana tells us how scared they all are
we can't sleep at night she says
whenever they hear sounds they think
it's another bombing and they run out of
the house
her husband says the war has completely
upended their lives and left them
terrified we've no idea what's going to
happen he says when it's going to happen
or where
they're still reeling from the shock of
it all and i think it follows a pattern
of an increasing number of civilians and
civilian targets or civilian locations
which appear to be
targeted or certainly not
um off the agenda of the the the russian
war machine
ukraine's former president petro
poroshenko has been busy rallying
volunteer fighters and soldiers
he's among a growing list of people
demanding safe passage for civilians
we were with him as he boosted morale
and championed the bravery of the troops
their job protecting the critically
important southern route out of the
capital is crucial and he brought fresh
weapons and supplies to help
if this route is taken by the russian
military the capital will be encircled
if ukrainians could win on defiance and
courage they would win but they need
more than defiance and courage don't
they and at the moment the capital is
slowly first of all
first of all remove the word if
we definitely win
this is first message
we we will win with
or without
western assistance
because you see how strong is ukrainian
but
it takes significantly more time and
will need significantly more lives
and blood and this is just
the decision from
our
partners in the west
do you
ready to give us the weapons do you
ready to increase the sanction
do you ready to do all of this to
minimize ukrainian blood and ukrainian
lives please do that immediately
the former president took us to see
another residential area which had been
hit
ukraine's heading for many more civilian
deaths he's warning and there are few in
the country confident enough to say
otherwise right now
alex crawford sky news in vassal kiev
he's already killed by iraq
joined now by the uk defense secretary
ben wallace uh and mr world thank you
very much for being with us this morning
we've seen in alex's report they're just
indiscriminate bombing of civilian areas
uh how is the wall going at this point
stage day 13 well it's not going
particularly well for the russians it's
day 13
way off their timetable
you know one level sadly the sing you
know there's a lot of casualties we've
seen the indiscriminate shelling which
has obviously killed numerous
civilians
we've also recognized that probably the
biggest single casualties so far russian
military soldiers who have
been let down by appalling leaders
pauling leadership and appalling plans
and now you see them literally
at large scales dying and i think that
is
something that will be interesting and
kremlin whether they will admit to each
other the failure of the aggressive and
illegal invasion of ukraine
we've seen the column is still stuck uh
north of kiev there are reports
overnight of ukrainian special forces
destroying uh you know over 20 russian
helicopters on the ground
and i think we can see that the russians
are having real logistic problems so
that affects morale they're not getting
through they're getting more desperate
and you can see them getting more
desperate because they're shelling more
and more innocent people just you know
trying to even get out on humanitarian
corridors as we saw yesterday
and i think this goes right to the heart
of the challenge for russia which is
russia has built itself a trap and it
sent itself in the international
community is knighted against them and
now we see
the devastation that they're leaving
behind we'll come on to a lot of that in
a moment but you saw in alex's report
there petro poroshenko the former
president of ukraine uh calling for more
western support we're going to hear from
president zielinski later today who will
no doubt call for more western support
are we doing all we can yeah we are
increasing our
support of both lethal and non-lethal
aid to ukraine we're continuing to
deliver them throughout the country we
started off obviously with two thousand
uh n laws that's a light-handed tank
weapons uh we've changed and increased
both the end laws and others and i'll
make a statement tomorrow i think to
parliament to give the details but
britain is stepping up doing that we're
supporting the coordination of delivery
throughout ukraine
and you know we were the first really to
do this in europe and we did it
obviously early in january way before
the invasion and so we're in a good
place to make sure they get better
defence and more defense and i'm in
touch with my colleague in in ukraine
quite a lot to get to know what's going
on and what they need i mean there is
some talk as well in the past couple of
days of uh reinforcing the ukrainian air
force by swapping out jets essentially
from nato members poland has been
mentioned with uh jets that the
ukrainian air force can use
your thoughts on that and whether that's
a viable thing to do at this stage of
the war well first of all there's any
there's very few nations that fly the
mig-29s which are the same
aircraft that the ukrainians fly so the
united kingdom's aircraft would not be
able to to be offered uh and so there
are only a few countries who potentially
could uh accept a request by the
ukrainians i would support the polls and
whatever choice they make it's those
whether they choose to do they choose or
not i mean you know
those countries are on the borders with
russia and ukraine to some extent and so
they will face a direct consequence and
so we would protect poland we'll help
them uh with anything and they need but
if they make that choice then that's a
choice they would have made
based on a view of bilaterally helping
ukraine and ukraine needing those now i
think ukraine should have whatever it
can have
to protect itself to defend itself from
this naked russian aggression to be
clear then you would support a nato
member essentially rearming
a bordering country against russia but i
think i would support their choice with
fighter jets you know all of us in these
jobs have to balance
the risk of escalation with helping what
we see on the ground
you know i i am responsible for the
security of the united kingdom and the
people and so is the prime minister and
you know we have to make sure
that the consequences of whatever
actions we do lethal aid included which
you know the russians have warned
there'll be retribution for countries
that have done that is calibrated in the
right way to make sure that there's not
an escalation into a war across europe
poland borders you know a number of
countries such as belarus that is an
active participant with russia in this
war and poland will understand that the
choices it make will not only directly
help ukraine which i think is a good
thing but also may bring them into
direct line of fire from countries such
as russia or belarus and they will have
to calibrate that that's a really big
responsibility on the shoulders of the
president of poland and indeed the
defense minister so it's not for me to
second guess their choice but it is for
me as a fellow nato member to say i will
stand by poland poland
al has been an ally for over 150 years
the united kingdom we will support
poland and whatever
choice she makes and also whatever she
needs as a result of that okay mr wells
let's move on then to the migration
issue of course as you know millions of
people on move let's just i want to show
you this picture here that we have
that's in a number of the newspapers
this morning
and that we've been featuring on sky
news that is the train station at karaki
i mean you know what that is reminiscent
of don't you from the 1940s
we can do more to help these people
can't we some 300 visas have been given
by the uk 10 000 wants to come here
can more be done and what do you think
about what you see there at kaikeev well
look that's what war in europe looked
like
70 or 80 years ago it's what war in
europe looked like today and i think
it's why people like me and the prime
minister determined to help ukraine
defend itself long before others were
because that was going to be the
consequence we warned
uh many countries in europe who were not
off the view russia would invade that
the risks were great migrant flows are
what happens in war and you know we
we've got used to wars a long way away
where people arrived on these shores and
european shores and drips and drabs
as they made it across uh territory
these people are neighboring the eu
they're neighboring europe
and quite rightly they're in a city that
is surrounded by russians who are
indiscriminately bombing them
uh of course we can do more and we are
doing more when i mean it's shameful
isn't it there's thousands there and 300
visas have been given look they're
processing seventeen thousand so
seventeen thousand people have applied
and they're being processed at the
moment and we've said we've said
over two hundred thousand people can
come here so the question really relies
on how many checks we do
once people reach a safe space so no one
is stopping those people getting across
their borders into a safe space and the
first and foremost duty for all of us is
to make sure those people get to safety
once they've got to safety making sure
we just check their identity before they
come to this country is incredibly
important that we do that it shouldn't
take time and i've offered you know and
i will be offering to the home office
assistance from the mad in the same way
we did not pitting to increase the
processing time to help those people uh
but but of course you know we have been
incredibly generous and we will continue
to be so we've said over 200 000 people
can come to this country i mean 200 000
people can come from ukraine too yes
they can come under the there's a range
of schemes the humanitarian scheme
there's the family scheme they can come
to this united kingdom the key here and
i understand the frustration is the
speed of processing when they get to a
safe country and that's the problem is
the speed of processing because you will
know that there have been stories in the
past 24 hours of people at
the uk border in calais unable to get
across even though they have every right
to come here why is that being said so i
know the home secretary is determined to
speed that up and you know the mod will
lean in as we did so you're not pitting
we we sent mod officials to help the
processing of identity to make it even
quicker we will play our part in
speeding that up you know we have people
in poland for example in the the
ministry of defense uh as as does the
home office they've done a pop-up visa
processing center but she recognizes
there's more to do you know what's there
at the moment is inadequate you do admit
that don't you look look i've said we
can do more there and we will lean in to
do that you know this is fast moving the
first duty is for the government to help
people get to safety and once they're in
safe countries poland or anywhere else
the next responsibility is to make sure
we process them as quick as possible of
course we can do that quicker we are
leaning into the home sector is
determined to do that quicker i will
give her all the support i can in making
sure it's done as quickly quick as
lightning okay uh mr wallace finally
then uh president zielenski is going to
address uh
mps today via video link he's been
described as a as a lion a real totem
for this war uh what kind of moment is
that going to be like in parliament when
he speaks to mps i think it's going to
be incredibly powerful you know um
president zielenski i've met on a number
of occasions
you know he is leading a country at war
i don't think he ever thought when he
was elected
as no one else really did or few people
did that russia was going to come and
decimate his country you know he is an
amazing guy he's a he's a he's actually
comes across as a very regular person
um it's been an incredibly unifying
moment for ukraine you know the last
president you've just seen on your uh
footage you know there's a joke in
ukraine that you know
russia has done one thing that the
ukrainian people haven't managed to
which is unite the former and the
current president you know that's what
happens when you invade the country
president obama is the spirit of ukraine
which is yang which is liberal thinking
which is outward facing which is
european and that's what russia or
president putin just doesn't understand
this is about values and who we are this
is not about the military threat that
was sort of made up by manufactured by
russia to itself
it's about the values and president
putin doesn't like the values that are
represented by nato and the eu and
that's what he's most angry about okay
ben wallace defense secretary do we
appreciate your time thank you very much
for being with us very busy but thank
you thank you very much for that
all right let's uh take you through some
of the morning's front pages of courses
one story that's dominating all of them
we'll start off with the telegraph
though which leads with the kremlin's
terms for a peace deal moscow claims
fighting could be halted almost
immediately if ukraine agrees to its
demands
look at the times well they say that
putin's plans are clearly mapped on the
face of its ukrainian victims a picture
they have a 55 year old woman who was
injured in shelling the guardian reports
that kiev has rejected russia's offer to
create humanitarian corridors we're
talking to the secretary of state about
that just now to allow civilians to flee
because most of those corridors leads to
russia and belarus
the front page of the metro
the ex-head of the army lord dana
insists that the uk must welcome more
refugees the headline pull your finger
out now because he made those comments
to my colleague kate burley on this very
show yesterday
and the ft reports on world markets
being rattled over fluctuations in oil
and gas prices after the united states
floated plans to ban the purchase of
russian oil
the daily mail it leaves with the prime
minister's plans for more drilling in
the north sea in a bid to stabilize
energy prices
and the sun let it go is the headline on
their front page it's a message to the
russian leader there's a video of a
young girl singing the popular song from
the disney movie frozen goes viral
we did show you that video on
yesterday's show as well
and the daily mirror reports on firms
apparently continuing to trade in russia
but shame is their headline despite all
we know that is happening with the
russian invasion of ukraine
well let's just take you now through the
latest developments in this war now
russia has not made any notable progress
in the past few days but has intensified
missile and artillery strikes on city
centers and civilian infrastructure the
capital kiev leve in the west and other
targets in the east were hit overnight
now russia had promised a ceasefire from
7 a.m this morning to allow civilians to
flee to safety from kiev chernihev
now local officials say that at least 10
people were killed in the north eastern
town of sumi when a missile hit a
residential plot
oktareka was also bombed and to the west
of ukraine's capital bombs hit oil
depots in sotomay
now more than 1.7 million people have
already fled the war and the u.n is
predicting that the exodus could reach 5
million well ester bunkel is on the
romanian border with ukraine and joins
us now again live alastair thank you for
being with us just uh before we speak
about what's happening with you you will
have heard what ben wallace had to say
your thoughts on uh his comments
regarding the the russian force in this
invasion
yeah ben wallace has
been consistently so strong through
throughout this crisis and before it um
obviously you gave him you know a hard
time on the number of
refugees that the the british have
accepted uh so far and i think it is uh
and i don't you know have all the
figures but i think i think lately it is
fair to say that the britain uh is
seeming to accept far fewer refugees
certainly than uh eastern european
allies um and so
quite rightly the british government is
being scrutinized about that i think
what i would say sort of in imbalance of
that is that leading up to uh this
conflict and throughout the conflict uh
britain has given an awful lot of
military aid support help training etc
to to the ukrainian armed forces i've
witnessed it myself over the last few
years and that is in no small part why
the ukrainian army is is able to fight
back against the russian forces in a way
that it just couldn't do in 2014 uh when
they came in and they they took uh
crimea um so
ben wallace is is naturally quite
defensive i think about what what
britain has done and is doing but i
think it is uh absolutely right that
there are further questions about why
britain has not let in more ukrainian
refugees who want to come to the uk at
the moment because
all i can say is that what we see here
is is a process where you are finding
tens and tens of thousands across the
entire border with well over one and a
half million now and it does seem to be
a process that is much smoother and much
more welcoming of people who are in
desperate need
okay alastair for now thank you very
much
and you can scan the qr code that you
see on your screen right now it's going
to pop up in just a moment's time there
it is i'll take you to today's edition
of the sky news daily podcast now in it
uh our correspondent insane rasheed will
look at whether more could be done by
the uk government to help those
ukrainian refugees as ben wallace was
saying some 200 000 are allowed to come
here as long as they pass the necessary
procedures now insulin will be hearing
from those trying to enter the country
and takes a look at how the uk visa
schemes work you can find it wherever
you find your podcasts or as i said by
scanning that qr code that you see right
now
all right some more positive news now
this morning we've heard some
heartbreaking stories since russia
invaded ukraine but young people are
using the social media app tick tock to
show their defiance against president
putin take a look at this
[Music]
oh that's a video from a tick tock user
called valarish as you can see here
she's kind of showing her life in a bomb
shelter and uh russian bombardment
makes you smile but also the cool irony
of it she has to live a life like this
is terrible in that music
obviously
we'll give you a little bit of a laugh
all right still together on sky news
breakfast
this is the latest from the ukrainian
capital he had another snowy morning on
day 13 of the russian invasion have
plenty more
on russia's invasion of ukraine
[Music]
i am there to speak truth to power one
question
but this is not this is a conversation
the format of the show so i'm going to
have an hour-long interview show once a
week on a thursday night it's at 9pm
it's a moment to press pause on this
frenetic pace of news and just reflect
on things and when we do have a
politician on the show you might see
them interviewed by me in a different
way than you perhaps normally see it
what they do
why they do it if i can find some of
that and bring it onto sky news i'd be
really happy
hello welcome back you're watching sky
news breakfast your top stories this
morning russia has intensified its
sharing of ukrainian towns and cities
according to the united nations 406
civilians have been killed since the
beginning of the russian invasion 13
days ago
[Music]
russia says it will implement a
ceasefire from 7am this morning to allow
civilians to escape from besieged cities
watching that closely as previous
attempts at a ceasefire have failed
and the ukrainian president vladimir
zelenki will address mps in the house of
commons via video link this evening
now in the past half hour the defense
secretary ben wallace has told me that
he would support other nations supplying
greater military assets to ukraine he
said he would be behind poland a nato
country if they decided to supply their
neighbors with fighter jets
well first of all there's any there's
very few nations that fly the mig-29s
which are the same
aircraft that the ukrainians fly so the
united kingdom's aircraft would not be
able to to be offered uh and so there
are only a few countries who potentially
could uh accept a request by the
ukrainians i would support the polls and
whatever choice they make it's those
whether they
those countries are on the borders with
russia and ukraine to some extent and so
they will face a direct consequence and
so we would protect poland we'll help
them
well uh political correspondent tomorrow
cohen is with us tomorrow thanks for
being with us so ben wallace there
saying that he would support poland in
whatever they decided to do whether they
wanted to send jets across the border
yes that's interesting this has been
under intense discussion over the last
few days actually kamali there was
initially an offer made by several
countries bordering poland but the
polish president then said that that
would constitute nato interfering
intervening in the war with russia so
but there's been talks going on we
understand with the u.s over the last
few days and it sounds like ben wallace
is very carefully saying that poland
would be able to make its own decision
to bilaterally send fighter jets to
ukraine if a way can be found to do that
and he would support them in that so he
says that the west has to do
everything it can to give ukraine what
it needs um to to fight this war while
balancing of course the risk of
escalation but he pointed out that
vladimir putin considers all
military aid to ukraine even that has
which has been sent by the uk so far uh
to be a step over the line so um he
thinks this is a risk worth taking it
was also interesting to hear from him
that the ministry of defense is going to
be helping the home office to speed up
processing of refugees clearly there's
an acknowledgement that that isn't going
fast enough yeah i mean a bilateral
support when you're part of a huge
defensive block seems like it might be a
difficult thing to do and yet he wasn't
quite sure as to how much help there was
at the border into the uk and only 300
visas have been uh accepted so far so
there's thousands of people still
waiting to come seventeen thousand i
think
yes he pointed out that seventeen
thousand applications have been made and
it's the processing which is slowing
things down he says that it's right to
do security checks it's right to work
out who people are so that you can help
them when they get to the uk and keep
track of them but that clearly isn't
happening quickly enough and he compared
it to the evacuation of afghanistan when
the ministry of defence were sent not
just to to do military tasks but also to
help the home office with processing
people and he says that they will be
offering their services again we're not
sure exactly what form that will take
whether it will be in the region or in
calais but clearly he thinks that that
needs to be sped up the offering
services i mean they did put on flights
before didn't i wonder if that would be
something they could consider tomorrow
for now thank you very much well
the uk government as we've just been
hearing has come under fire for not
adopting a more open policy for
ukrainians fleeing war but even for
those with family here in the uk the
route can be challenging hundreds of
people in calais have been told they
have to go to paris to get their papers
processed action horizon reports
when eight-year-old zlata cried down the
phone to her mum as the war raged
outside her bedroom window mariana flew
from the uk to her rescue after days of
travelling they reunited on the polish
ukrainian border i just called like her
name's lata sata it was very emotional
that everyone could hide it
despite mariana working as a nanny in
london for six years the pair were
turned away at calais unable to re-enter
the uk because mariana's asylum
application is still being processed her
mum meanwhile has stayed behind if they
get bombed this place so it's be so many
people be dead so she needed to get out
yes a hundred percent my mom said oh she
also worried and she just tell me
i leave all this like important paper
she just tell me like where she leave
important paper so if something happened
you know where is this paper
but i hope this videos
an appointment with border force
officials in paris is their best bet for
crossing the channel
david and his ukrainian wife and
children wait on dover's doorstep for
the same outcome after coming under fire
in eastern ukraine and finally making it
to france they too were barred from the
uk they've been told they need to drive
three hours to paris to now apply for a
family visa
why can't i go home with my family my
ukrainian family i'm not asking for
nothing from the government i can pay
for everything myself
i just want to take my family home and
protect them that's all i want to do
we've heard from people who have been
waiting for news in paris those here in
calais who've been turned away and even
those in the uk who are confused about
their visa status but as they seek
sanctuary their worries deepened to for
the family and friends they've left
behind
those like maria she's in derby visiting
her mum on a holiday visa which expires
within weeks she's been told she can
stay but can't find clear guidance i see
that uk government is doing something i
see that they are trying to make it
better for ukrainian refugees
but well
please
do more please
allow people even not relatives to come
well we are good people we're just
trying to escape the war
a plea many are hopeful will be heard
but tens of thousands are applying
knowing there's no guarantee of success
ash naharinag sky news in calais
well maria timofienko has managed to
help her 69 year old mother reach the uk
but she's now unsure whether she'll be
able to do the same for other members of
her family and i'm pleased to say that
maria joins us now maria good morning to
you and thank you very much for being
with us so just tell us how are you able
to get your mother out
good morning andrea thank you
uh my mother was able to come to the uk
because she
had a visa prior to all the situation
and
she had a very difficult terrifying
journey across ukraine but now she is in
safety she is with me
she is very stressed and
suffering a lot about what's happening
back home and of course we have extended
family
who are still in ukraine
and whom at the moment i cannot invite
to the uk
and uh
um i i wish that there would be a way
which would allow me to take them and
sponsor them to come to the uk
where abouts are your family maria at
the moment you will have heard uh we had
the defense secretary on just a moment
ago saying that anyone who applies will
be able to enter the uk as long as they
pass the procedures where are your
family right now
uh from my last interview you may
remember i have i had my aunt uh on on
on the news here uh she was based in
kiev uh and was determined to stay but i
managed to convince her to leave kf now
uh after um after the reports of what we
have seen in european in the north of
kiev about the army advancing i managed
to convince my aunts and my uh cousin to
leave kf and they're now heading uh on
the road to leve
and they will be there
for the time being
and have you started the process of
trying to bring your aunts and cousins
in have you been in touch with the home
office and whoever else you need to to
start that process of trying to sponsor
them
i am working on that um i understand
that at the moment they are not a
category that is allowed to come in
so i'm waiting for clarification from
the home office about the sponsor visa
for
extended family and for non-relatives
because besides my family i also have
contacts and friends who
are also in very difficult circumstances
those are mostly
mothers with children
and grandparents
who left their husband behind husbands
behind
and they are
either on the way to the border across
the border so i would like to help as
many people as i can but for this we
need a clear guidance from the home
office
about how we can sponsor people uh and
to ensure that this process is as as as
straightforward as possible so that they
are not enduring even more suffering uh
on top of what they have already have
experienced escaping from the war
maria let's make this really clear so if
anyone is listening they can understand
exactly what needs to change so you can
bring your loved ones and your relatives
to you in the uk you're able to sponsor
your mother because of who you are and
your status within the united kingdom
you're not asking for these people to be
put up in a in some other accommodation
you're going to look after them yourself
that's the process you're seeking to
follow and you want to bring these
people here under your own control and
you will be paying for them to stay here
for now
yes absolutely we have luckily we have
space and we are actually now
building some extended accommodation
just to be able to host people but
anyone who wants to come here they don't
want um you know to come to just benefit
from the society here they want to
actually contribute to work so they are
um the people who have um professions so
it's important to find ways for them to
integrate to to work to earn money uh to
get their kids to school uh to provide
them with the support that they need
okay maria timothy fianco i do
appreciate your time again it's nice to
speak to you again i know you're on our
show quite often i wish you luck and you
will be in touch in the next coming days
to see how you're getting on thank you
for being with us this morning thank you
thanks maria
all right let's just bring you a little
bit of breaking news that's coming into
us here at sky news it's coming from the
interfax news agency it's a russian news
agency so obviously we take this with a
little bit of a pinch of salt but it
does say that russian forces have held
fire in ukraine from at 7am this morning
that's part of the ceasefire to allow
humanitarian corridors for civilians to
evacuate areas that are encircled by
russian forces of course the russian
forces say they've held fire from 7am
now many of those humanitarian corridors
that have been set up are headed in to
russia or into belarus meaning that many
of the people who are able to use them
really don't want to but russian forces
are saying that from 7am this morning
they have held fire we'll keep an eye on
that throughout the morning and see how
that pans out for the rest of the day
now the prime minister has warned that
the uk can't simply move away from
russia's oil and gas as prices surge
sky's paul kelso has been looking at how
the impact will be felt in the uk and
the rest of europe
the invasion of ukraine has sent energy
prices soaring with huge implications
for the global economy and household
budgets but has the time come to take
the ultimate sanction and ban russian
oil that was a suggestion from u.s
secretary of state anthony blinken at
the weekend and just look what it did to
the oil price already rising since the
invasion on february the 24th it
exceeded 139
a barrel at one point before falling
back and prices for next day delivery of
natural gas past 600 pence a therm
that's almost double previous records
that have driven up domestic fuel bills
and these price spikes came from just
talking about an energy boycott and
while the west talks russia profits it's
the world's third largest oil producer
behind the us and saudi arabia turning
out around 11 million barrels a day
that's more than 10 percent of global
production but it's the world's largest
exporter it sells more than anyone else
abroad and this is where it goes germany
takes 30 percent of its oil from russia
france and italy and the uk more than 10
south korea the us and japan are also
customers all major economies fueled by
russian oil and europe is even more
reliant on russian gas you can see the
countries at the top of this chart in
the east of europe get almost all of
their supplies from russia but germany
and italy take almost half france nearly
a quarter though the uk imports just
four percent so the taps can't just be
turned off the global economy would have
to be weaned off russian oil with
alternative sources found but that might
mean conversations with suppliers like
iran or venezuela themselves sanctioned
which explains why european leaders are
more cautious about a boycott
if you now would force european
companies to quit doing business with
russia that would have um enormous
ramifications uh around europe including
ukraine but also around the world so we
have to dramatically reduce our
dependency
on gas and oil from russia that will
take time an oil ban would certainly
hurt the russian economy but every
weapon in this economic war comes at a
price and families and consumers across
europe could pay it
well still to come on sky news breakfast
we'll hear how the war in ukraine is
affecting some of the countries most
vulnerable and a plea to help get them
out
[Music]
hello and welcome back now leaving a war
zone is fraught with difficulty and for
those with a disability fleeing the
fighting can be even more challenging
now i'm joined by julia satchuk the head
of fight for the right ukraine an
organization that promotes the rights of
disabled people in the country yulia
good morning to you and thank you for
being with us and now i know that you
are in kiev just tell us what it's like
in the city right now
actually i'm not in cave now i'm in
budapest but yes we
continue to work for evacuation and
support people with disabilities in
ukraine
and regarding this situation it is very
different in different
regions
but the problem is
the general lack of communication and
systemic work regarding providing safety
and evaluation for people with different
types of disabilities
especially for those with severe
disabilities especially who are in close
institutions like psychiatric
institutions and hospitals
people who need
special accessible uh transportation
and
uh people with disabilities in occupied
cities like bucha like uh kharkiv sumo
people still there they are looking for
any chance to survive their calling for
international organizations
and they don't receive
uh sufficient attention
and my apologies uh thinking that you're
in here if you're in budapest just
describe if you can
your journey out of the country
my journey
my journey started from the bomb
shelters but my journey
as a person with disability you know i
didn't have chances to survive by myself
and it's only like
because
one of my colleague and friend was with
me and
thanks for her
we were succeeded to leave the country
it was very difficult it was very
dangerous but
and i think
i didn't find strengths to make it by
myself
because i also was with my son my sister
and uh
due to my visual impairments for me it
will be
not
like possible to start this journey so
it's only like uh
her support
helped me to
escape from the war
newly we do hear stories just like that
of amazing courage that people are
showing all working together to make
sure that they can get out of the war
zone i wonder if you can describe how
people with disabilities living in
ukraine prior to this war uh were being
treated as their much uh
sort of social structures support for
the
disabled community
yes we have uh we have um
ministry of social affairs we have
ministry of health who's helped people
they provide like this month's uh
uh
monies or other um privileges uh for
people with disabilities but situation
at all uh our country unfortunately
uh
didn't um
didn't implement a convention on the
rights of people with disabilities and
um you know in
situation of usual life
we uh like start we
were fighting for this but when the
situation is terrible like now when this
is about your life not just a
comfortable life but
like
life
your right to life it's very big is that
any ins international instrument um
standards they don't work in this
situation and i really curious
why this happened and
um yesterday we received a very i don't
know sad message from our friends couple
uh who use wheelchair they are in
[ __ ] and you know it seems like
uh the last the that was their calling
the last calling to all international
community to ukrainian authorities
to help them they are very famous they
are activists they doing a lot for
people with disabilities community in
ukraine now they are more than 10 days
in the basement and they don't have any
chance to survive
and for me it's like really
really difficult to receive such
messages each day and i don't know to
whom
call and
from where
uh receive this support in this
situation such organization like
red cross world hell or health
organization and other
they keep silent there is no system of
uh force support and evocation of people
with disabilities in ukraine now
no absolutely not at a time of war the
most vulnerable are often the ones who
who suffer the most okay julia satric we
are pleased that you managed to get out
safely i do hope for the best for your
friends that are able to get out and for
all those in ukraine who are suffering
during this invasion julia thank you
very much for joining us this morning
thank you
well you're watching sky news breakfast
this is the latest picture from
ukrainian capital kiev on day 13 of the
russian invasion more on the wall after
the break
[Music]
you